a nation watching the man who will
direct the country from emergency
to recovery every step he's ever taken
as chancellor has been
unprecedented
[Music]
all eyes on him for a budget which will
for the first time
reveal his vision of what post-pandemic
post-brexit britain
actually looks like mr chancellor of the
exchequer
but first the consequences of still
being in lockdown what was originally
thought to be a temporary disruption to
our way of life
has fundamentally altered it much has
changed
but one thing has stayed the same
i said i would do whatever it takes
i have done and i will do so
extending emergency economic support to
the autumn
which means it will have been in place
for 18 months
the furno extended to september
self-employed grants extended to
september
universal credit uplift extended to
september
kickstart restart a lifetime skills
guarantee
business rates cut vat cut
stamp duty cut and a new mortgage
guarantee
the first part of a budget that protects
the jobs and livelihoods
of the british people but all adding up
to 406 billion pounds of emergency
support over two years
enough to make chancellors of any
stripes swallow hard
this has consequences the damage
done by coronavirus combined with a
level of support
unimaginable only 12 months ago has
created
huge challenges for our public finances
the amount we've borrowed is comparable
only
with the amount we borrowed during the
two world wars
that likely to cause conservative
jitters much like the prime minister's
posture
corporation tax up after years of tory
reductions
and income tax thresholds frozen but it
was what he didn't say which gave the
opposition an opening
we needed a budget to fix the
foundations of our economy
to reward our key workers to protect the
nhs
and to build a more secure and
prosperous economy for the future
instead what we got was a budget that
papered over the cracks
and although the chancellor spoke for
almost an hour
we heard nothing about a long-term plan
to fix
social care it was a budget of two
halves
65 billion pounds more of emergency
pandemic relief with one principal aim
to stave off the specter of mass
unemployment
the government's forecasters suggest
actually the numbers on that
now are going in the right direction but
then a defining
gamble from rishi sunak a
massive hugely expensive tax break for
companies
at a time where he was saying little
about public services
and proposing tax rises around the time
of the next election
and a tory chancellor raising the burden
of those tax rises to the highest levels
since the 1960s
these are very big tax rises indeed it's
the biggest tax
raising budget since 1993 so in nearly
30
years and it will take if all delivered
are the tax burden in this country to
its highest level his highest
sustained level ever the man in number
11 wants to kick-start britain
bring back growth with business at the
fore
will it deliver what the country needs
sam coates sky news